hi I'm Greg and I'm drank - Greg - and
Greg one are gonna watch ask a porn star
oh really weird porn scenes found chicka
Bow Wow I can't find the request but
it's booked monological ow
have you seen porn we go one time
actually my dad had a video store he had
an adult section or dating I would sneak
in and I would lift up the blue tape
from all of the videos and I'd be like
genitals and that's how I learned what's
next was Wow amazing
that's fine the first porn I ever watch
was called I swear to God Edward penis
hands it was like Edward Scissorhands
but he just said no yeah what there's
hands penises yeah just to tilt so it's
just the acting minute very i watch porn
food acting that's what inspired you
yeah I think I'm gonna be an actor after
you know we're in a generation where
kids who watch porn on the internet
right we had to like find porn true yeah
it was like a thing you have to look for
yeah in night Google search the the X
Express or whatever like that's like
yeah you can't Google dude um my dad
would have things mailed to him like to
buy the adult videos and every time I
come home from school I'd look in the
mailbox and I would see like a magazine
wrapped in like black plastic and I knew
it was something and so I would like
steal them and like I would like look at
them for research for
[Music]
the weirdest porn scene I've been in is
such a hard question for me because I've
done a lot of weird [ __ ] weird is in
like one of my step family or weird as
in leg I had sex with somebody in full
body paint that was like a cartoon
character are we talking about murder
Porter like a regular porn fetish stuff
is always definitely a little bit
strange oh okay the one where I put
sticks of butter up jinx mazes [ __ ]
who hasn't that one well the men Jackson
stop and someone got stuck we'll be gone
about getting golf balls stuck in your
ass isn't weird it's just a Tuesday
afternoon oh I've done like farting
Clips before I took the little fish tank
pump things like the little tubes and
like put it in my butthole like pumped
air up so perlis air my like I could
feel it all here just not push farts out
so that was kind of weird myself
[Music]
Japanese companies porns that I've shot
they have some interesting fetishes like
sleeping I did little [ __ ] of the Rings
part two and they blew a tree I've been
an alien space captain I've been a
naughty big teddy Kenny I have been a
dead body that's been [ __ ] in the
morgue I got [ __ ] by the person that
was supposed to be getting my body
prepped for my funeral I had like bounce
on balloons and apparently that's a
fetish that I didn't know but guys like
to see girls bounce up and down on
balloons actually recently it was a
thumb Dom work that I was doing in New
York and it was ball busting there was a
slave who he actually enjoys it and he
does this like all the time but I have
never seen anyone of my life get kicked
in the balls over 50 times with
with spikes on the heels and I mean to
directly just in the nuts and the nuts
and then oh well nothing okay
people always cringe when they hear it
because it's like kicking a guy in the
next over over or stomping on them or
something along those lines and the
thing is is people go what why would you
do that and I was like trust me
the guy I did it to has a fetish so he
friggin love oh how can i how can i feel
bad when you know that you're making
somebody happy I don't know I think it's
a tie between being Rocket Raccoon and
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle parody
their turtles I never actually thought I
would see like the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles with giant green [ __ ] you know
shooting out like toxic the secret of
the use me [ __ ] my step-brother I
love like the daddy-daughter
brother-sister like that incest not
really incest that seems like a lot of
like stepmonster plain or like
stepsister okay to me the concept of
that I guess was a little bit weird I
think all the stepdaughters
step-siblings stuff is really weird it's
not real I don't know I've done some
incest scenes and the weird thing about
it was I was supposed to have sex with
this beautiful black man and my stepdad
was watching no one really knows why the
daddy-daughter porn season that I did
just because I had such a like close
relationship with the father figure I
had to do a scene like that and put
myself in a position because that has
never crossed my mind ever
but the scenes that like creep me the
[ __ ] out that I've done a few of our the
mommy-daughter scenes and when I'm
putting a scene in the directors like
yeah give me where mommy talk or [ __ ]
move on here like hey your students
mommy talk the whole time inside I'm
just cringing and late no I don't like
it you know role playing is like such a
safe way to do things that we shouldn't
do in real life definitely when I played
Patrick and SpongeBob SquarePants
because I had to wear the whole starfish
character like I see that and do the
boys I did a movie called poor little
Shila and I play and I have like
problems and so they put me embraces you
know you can't discriminate against a
disabled person and they got to get laid
- it was like bondage I was tied up and
I had a piece of bamboo so I was like
position my legs were open and I was
getting [ __ ] in the ass all day it was
just really really after they got me
down from that position
they literally strapped my hair in
pigtails around this guy's ass and made
me eat his ass I've heard of like girls
gaping other girls asses and peeing and
them are just like crazy hard bondage
people squirting in my gate so squirting
is female ejaculation and gape is when
your butthole stays open like your
muscles are so relaxed that it stays
open so I was gaping and then somebody
squirted into it the sex location it
will be on a forklift it was very
difficult to learn great things like
this back to loom and it was kind of
like weird they like you know like
spread your [ __ ] away so that was kind
of weird it was really weird like I
don't know
well like that but this particular scene
was honey weird we had all these things
and we [ __ ] got covered we like start
throwing pies at each other we were
naked we were naked all of a sudden
that's where I was tied up in a gigantic
frying pan basted in oil like a chicken
and then it was a girl-girl scene and
the other girl was like going to eat me
but not like eat me but actually like
yeah it's okay I'm I'm still here it all
turned out all right but um but yeah
that was really weird I was like
surrounded by that Jesus stuff I think
adventure time might be the weirdest
scene that I've done just having to
think cartoon having horns that are
aware of its when you are harm to
yourself or to others so my whole
scenario was that I tried to commit
suicide in the psych ward I and imagine
being gangbanged by the orderlies and
like one of the other patients does and
at some point in the dream I'm coming
out until the hallway of the hospital
and they throw a bunch of like confetti
get me and just start you know like
welcome to your pity party and they like
[Music]
I got to play through assault and I jump
regularly music yo why don't you you
know and I'm like excuse me sir that's
very unprofessional if you keep it up
I'll bring a male nurse to come in and
finish the job hypnosis and then it's
just me bathing him I'm giving you a
[ __ ] and then the next day in this
little pool the person wanted was come
really be completely messy so I had
pudding HBU and I had whipped cream and
then I had to put these boots on and
then I had to take all of the stuff and
literally cover myself I've done one
ripe and wrapped in secret oh good old
kitchen saran wrap and it's been cut off
with a knife I did wet messy pies of
shaving cream all like this so I'm a big
marshmallow puff of shaving cream times
it's like marshmallow fluff or anything
along those lines and then it was a
custom so I had to have a cigarette
which I don't smoke so it was like a
closed cigarette so I have cigarette
company has some limits yes doctor this
is going to help me quit smoking that
will probably be the weirdest one I shot
a video cover myself with a bottle of
shaving cream and then
I had to masturbate myself to an orgasm
and then I took it another step and I
just pissed all over the floor
typical day Wow
that was something special for everyone
here
Craig subscribe to would rock it you
want to watch porn stick yeah let's just
turn off the camera just watch actual
porn cool you go first ease and I'll go
seconds and then honestly though I only
listen to porn so I don't actually watch
it I just do auditory your auditory yeah
inaudible not even like moaning or like
shrieking it's just soothing sounds of
Barbra Streisand I just listen to that
and I just I pleasure myself okay we can
do that thanks dude
no you can get Barbra Streisand sounds
it's amazing yeah absolutely it's just
you know funny girl she's just like I'm
gonna be a star I'm never doing had sex
with Barbra Streisand
what's your music that you listen to I
just hope all of these women and men who
are in this industry do it safely and
actually enjoy doing it like she was
saying like getting kicked in the balls
like a lot like some people think that
hurts most people most people I think
would say getting kicked in the balls
some people enjoy it so to each their
own but I do hope that these women enjoy
that job and enjoy the act of sex and
it's not something that yeah like
quote-unquote forced into I mean we both
notice that the women in this video
looks significantly more on flight I
don't want say they're unhappy but yeah
the men look happy sure especially that
one dude
with the curly hair just laksa yeah skip
my [ __ ] things cool is there
something to do with like if you want to
get deep with it Shane is more involved
in porn to women than it is to men
because of just you may like be actual
porn actors yeah yeah um I feel like
with porn Watchers Shane is more
involved with men but you never hear
about a woman with like porn addiction
what are you here about men all the time
yeah but yeah I think you're right about
that every time I hear about like any
documentary they make about what porn is
evil or something it's always like a
bunch of women talking about why it's
like sinister and stuff totally men just
love it I don't know the reason of that
type of stimulation just go out and like
I mean you could look at porn everybody
looks at porn but just go outside and
like do real life porn like have a
conversation with like a hot person and
then they'll they'll be like you're hot
too on the inside and out and then you
just can go home and you can cover each
other in the foods and like you know
pretend to be brother and sister you can
like do your your thing dresses as a
cartoon to adventure time and do it for
real you can have a real life porn if
you just go out there and you try okay
you don't have to be locked away in your
house teasing her and it's scarier to go
out there to put yourself out there but
I promise real life porn is better than
real life like watching porn this time
or you know ever ever like zoom like
talk like a lot of TED talks on this
another like random videos I've seen
where they talk about how think you're
thinking of head talk how like guys who
are like active poor watchers tend to
get like the least action actually
really because they're kind of just
finding their release there are no
through this instead of containing that
in them they're like releasing it
through through watching a video or
something yeah so they're not they don't
feel the desire as strong to motivate
them or make them more confident to go
out and meet women right I mean you
that's so interesting I have a
girlfriend now and so it's like I don't
watch a lot of porn I used to watch a
lot of porn but then when you get like
you know the
my girlfriend and I don't have sex we
sleep in separate beds we're waiting for
marriage it's you know it's I'm putting
that out there parallelism exactly but
she she gives me everything that like
she I don't need that type of thing
and it actually makes me feel strange
watch it cuz I haven't watched porn so
long having them talk about it makes me
uncomfortable
like I knew is that am i becoming a more
mature or something or it's a great
thing yeah that's a great thing everyone
has heard about it foreign is unhealthy
or okay or does it help in some way
right but from my experience in life or
just with talking with people or doing
research on this topic it seems that
it's it's better without it
yeah research I just watched a lot and
asked myself okay and every night it's
been like that for the past three months
you know this I'm very ashamed it's
gonna get okay I'm gonna get okay dude
don't worry it's gonna get okay when
I've met girls who watch porn they can
like settle for like a video and then
just sticking with this one video I came
across you know really like the bill
certainly I think the craziest one I
came across where was like five guys is
because when I when I've watched porn or
the restaurant five guys in the porn
it's just about five guys in five guys
like Edie see when I've watched porn
it's like you just find a video oh she's
hot zoom alright move on I don't likes
it I don't like watch one video I tend
to it'll be like a few when I watched
sure but doing that you come across some
crazy porn sometimes they end up just
not drinking off to but just watching
yeah and now interesting sociologically
or like the psychology of thorn is
really like like why we watch it or like
it's such a strange thing like if you
take yourself out of it like we're just
like these
watching other animals yeah it's like
badges or just like like I guess it's
like we're putting ourselves there but
in a way everything is like it's about
connection maybe that's it yeah
well that's what I think I feel I don't
usually enjoy it like it's like I'll
enjoy when it's happening but once I'm
done I'm like what kind of empty yeah so
I don't laugh I usually don't like to
watch as much as I like talked to joked
about more on this channel yeah I
usually don't enjoy watching right most
of the time that's why I like having
like finding a real relationship
connection totally that's pretty that's
reeking like you could have sex and have
like a [ __ ] orgasm and it's you for
it I've never liked you I just watched
porn I feel great right like this is how
you could tell how bad porn is when
you're the moment you climax how quickly
do you X out of it just like you feel
bad see if I've watched it a couple
times of like girls I've been with yeah
that's different
I find that different but you can ever
watch it with girls you've been this is
when improv on stage gets confusing
called me in years I think it went if I
masturbated with just my imagination
like that seems more natural you know if
I but if I'm by myself watching porn
it's not natural for me to just be like
looking at a screen and like getting off
to like random people [ __ ] that's
just it seems so artificial but if I
feel like I'm with it when I'm with
someone like if we're watching it if I'm
with a girl we're both into it I'm still
sharing that connection and experience
with that girl even though we're
watching porn right I'm not alone on
this it's like we're here together so
there's still a connection
so then I don't feel like you know like
oh this is void right but but no I would
say like 95 percent at the time when I
watch more I'm like no this is every
time I'm done watching porn I'm like
this will be the last time that's
literally like cuz it always sounds like
a good idea like men think about sex you
know they say five six times a day or
whatever
maybe it's the statistics more than that
that sounds low five or six times a day
I just I like gay men because watch the
most porn out of everyone because they
just seem the most fun and excited about
like sex and so even the the men and
this are excited about having just sex
as a job that I've got the main Watchers
of porn or gay men I'm gonna just play
about I hear get I hear gay porn is like
the most profitable act that's
profitable yeah like especially if
you're gonna be a male porn actor yeah
you gotta be like okay that's why I
never did it yeah well maybe not maybe
next year maybe next year when I go gay
yeah
the choice you make I just like um I'm
always down to be in porn
but I just need creative control one day
we're gonna bridge that gap yeah we're
just gonna be when they will bridge that
gap where we're gonna know we're gonna
have porn where it's gonna be like yeah
we're gonna get there at that point
where what is the line between porn
because we talked about Gasper no that
was that movie but like it's called
irreversible as a 17 minute rape scene
it's really intense and it's just it's
there the actors actually doing it no no
but it's it's their acting but it's I
mean yeah but you've after the first two
minutes you're just like I don't know
is acting and it's like makes you real
uncomfortable and it's a it's a feeling
I never had when I watched a movie but
like the that there's a fine line
because like you watch stuff like Gasper
know stuff and you go this is very
pornographic but it's not considered
porn because it's artistic but then
what's the line what's that right
exactly
so if we can make poor more artistic
right that's Gasper know we think about
it we're always talking about diversity
in Hollywood
I think porn is more diverse than any
part of all who look true yeah not all
kinds of end this is these broken into
categories amazing out there
you want your agents of blacks they got
the category the winner is gag on boy I
mean la la la all right guys you can
subscribe but what about we talked about
porn for like 15 16 is awesome let's
talk about porn for and would rocket
subscribe to them describe to the real
regex nate Harley Nahar Oh hardly
Oh hardly Hartley broken Hartley but now
our full Hartley Nate full heart Hartley
my porn name is hardly heart poor name
is Jeff Sanchez it's not even that dirty
it's just it's just nice Jeff Smith yeah
um Nate hardly follow me on instagram
i'm i'm doing the Goldbergs that's on
ABC check your local listings I'm loving
life you should too I hope your kids
bring a mushroom
[Laughter]